Anastasia
beaverhousen Anastasia like Russian
royalty Beaver housing
like where the beaver
[Music]
live thanks Smitty Mrs Walker I hate to
be IND delicate but oh right right right
right right the tab oh now what was our
agreement again one month or $1,000
whichever comes
first my word has it been a month
already no
ma'am
Smitty what's it all
about oh wait I don't give a
[Applause]
crap
Karen
no Karen it's you I'm sorry you must
have mistaken me for somebody else my
name is Anastasia
beaverhousen oh all right all right it's
me what in the hell are you doing here s
like a drink and you know sometimes you
want to go where nobody knows your
name yeah well you're not going to like
it here nobody's going to serve you a
drink and a leather thong and a dog
collar what are we doing at Taco Time
and wait did you bring that drink from
the
restaurant what is this
Vegas look
Karen don't call me by my real name call
me by my Alias Anastasia Beaver
housing I want to be in
cocko why who could possibly know you
here I don't
know H Duchess of
York what why would the dut oh my God
it's
parking do you think that Weight
Watchers knows about
this what is going on here Taco Time is
a guilty pleasure for some of the ladies
in my circle nobody questions
it nobody talks about
it okay I say yes on the pants yes on
the sweater and definitely yes with the
other decision you're struggling with
[Applause]
okay Jack oh hey
Karen I'm Anastasia Beaver
housing why are you using your Alias
because I passed a couple of bad checks
here you know for
sport Eber housing can you believe it
me a Banana Republic sales associate and
my guidance counselor said i' never
amount to
anything honey I'm so proud of you come
on let's go to Barney there's a new
sales girl there and we got to get her
fired she has a gray tooth come
on I can't I'm working hello well yeah
and I'm ovulating but nothing's going to
come of that
either you don't understand I have
responsibilities look a headset you know
this isn't working this is going to
interfere with our friendship I work a
40-hour month for what's her name and I
always make time for us come on I can't
all right but I promise nothing's going
to change between us hey I'll come over
later and we'll short sheet Rosario's
bed then we can take a big bubble bath
together nothing would give me more
pleasure than to sponge clean the beaver
housing Wilma
Anastasia hi my name is Anastasia
beaverhousen tell me did you intend the
reader to have an erotic reaction to the
grizzly murder of the well- muscled
handyman did you have
one I have
three then
yes uh sorry you had a question what are
you doing here we had important plans to
go get bikini waxes little night now yes
now I've been steaming my gals all
day it cuts down the irritation on my
wenus come on let's go she does she
wants to stay the go she wants to stay
the go she wants to stay now go faster
and talk
dirty you have a very delightful
chuckle thank you they're real
too Glo Banks
Lio like the train Banks like money and
you
are Anastasia
beaverhousen Anastasia like Russian
royalty beaverhousen
like where the beaver
live
Dynamite but brings you to this Lush
Paradise Miss Beaver
how oh I don't know really just killing
time I
suppose waiting for something good to
happen
interesting I was just doing the same
thing looks like my wait is
over well well where did you come from
Lionel did the smooth talking jiggalo
convention let out
early listen why don't we continue this
in my very comfortable Suite upstairs
I've got loads of cash so time is no
issue Mr Banks you think I'm a
hooker party those clothes that
voice
yes where where is Karen I have no idea
shh there is no
Karen I'm sister Francis beaverhousen
[Applause]
well I got there too late one of those
ushers had already taken my flask to the
manager's office calm down I'll go talk
to the manager I'm sure we can work
something out surprised you can wear
that thing without your skin Burning uh
I'm
29 welcome to
Ohio we're in a league and we're one
short is there any way you could fill
in I don't think so our friend Peg
couldn't make it cuz her hatchback
wouldn't start you're your story has
moved me I'm
in great I'm Jean and this is
Rhonda Anastasia
beaverhousen nice to meet you now I'll
need a 12lb ball and a big plate of
fried food from the looks of this place
my ass has got a lot of catching up to
do if that man only had one day left and
you could help him to live it honestly
then that's what you should be
doing what is more important than living
life is your most authentic self you're
up
Anastasia palow Bail Bonds is going to
the
semifinals you suck me very animal
h